ça fait longtemps que je m'intéresse aux
différences entre les hommes et les
femmes dans la société
demain de par mon parcours
professionnels universitaires et
associatifs
et justement en me documentant sur ces
sujets là un jour je suis tombé sur une
statistique qui m'a laissé bouche bée
qui est que la population carcérale
masculine en france représentent 96 % du
total et donc je me suis demandé qu'est
ce que ça voulait dire de la violence
dans notre société qu'est ce que ça
voulait dire de la délinquance et de la
criminalité des hommes dans notre
société et en creusant un peu voilà je
me suis rendu compte qu'il représentait
83% des mis en cause par la justice 90%
des personnes condamnées par la justice
96 % donc de la population carcérale et
que si on regarde par type d'infraction
ils sont surreprésentés dans tous les
types d'infractions et notamment les
plus graves
voilà on peut encore citer quelques
chiffres 86% des auteurs de meurtres 99%
des auteurs de viol
84% des auteurs d'accidents mortels de
la route etc etc et donc une fois que
j'avais ces chiffres à ma portée lorsque
j'ai vu dans la rue comme tout un chacun
des services de secours se déplacent et
je me suis dit que c'était probablement
un homme qui avait commis l'infraction
puisque bien je dis bien que si tous les
hommes ne sont pas meurtrier délinquants
l'immense majorité donc des meurtriers
et des délinquants ce sont des hommes on
l'a vu à travers ses chiffres et donc je
me suis dit qu'il y avait effectivement
des services de secours des services de
santé s'il y avait des victimes
également de la justice qui se met en
place la police il y à une enquête et
caetera et caetera et donc je me suis
dit que tout cela avait un coût qui
devait être faramineux et qui n'avait
jamais calculé et c'est comme ça que
j'en suis venu à donc écrire cet essai
le coût de la virilité
[Musique]